I'm gonna work through the solutions and
then each time I finished I'll show you
where the marks are assigned now this is
a bit tricky for me
because I thought I have to win two hats
at the same time let me explain what I
mean I've already told you oh yes yes
I've already told you that there are
some weird things about agency marking
that are kind of characteristic to
agency might only and we try to mimic it
in certain ways but we consciously try
not to mimic it in other ways example
I've already told you about this one
before if I give you this question okay
what would you say the answer was you
remember that I said you know Internet
receives here which has plenty of
integration questions okay
there will be one place at one place
only when they're actually going to
deduct the mark for the constant not
being there okay
so that means that by and large if you
see a question like this and answer it
like that if they just see that more
than likely we'll get through and we'll
get there will be nothing deducted from
them okay now it's so true you want to
be honest it would only be but at one
month even were in that section where
they were deducting for the constant of
integration and it didn't have it it
just gives you because you get zero or
one it's not correct enough to be able
to warrant a hallmark okay and because
the the actual integral itself is so
simple and straightforward you don't
really get anything like that's not a
free bar okay so therefore constantly
I'm going to be talking about what gets
accepted right versus what I'm gonna
encourage you guys to put marks on and
not put marks on because can you imagine
what would happen if you are the teacher
and the way that you explain a question
like this right to your students whoa
look this will get through most of the
time so don't worry about the cluster
it'll be rough she'll be right you know
whatever that's a bad idea as a teacher
because then you're sitting up really
powerful habits even if it does
hey that's kind of not the point yeah so
what I'm going to do is particularly
where it seems quite simple I'll try and
explain burrows where that diverge okay
right let's have a go at this first on
the integral and this is the question
yeah okay now we've kind of done these
two Devin haven't we
it's three marks and it's an easy three
miles that's why it's in question two
because they even supply the
substitution okay so being that it's
three marks and the answer is very
simple you really need to look for the
working in that it's all set up if you
just have this okay does anyone know
know what this has this has a name when
you just see an answer on time hasn't it
it's generally called a more than answer
answer we learn hand it's just the
answer sitting on its own no explanation
justification working the maximum that
the ball dads who are receiving the HSC
no matter how much the whole question is
worth is one mark one mark it doesn't
matter if the whole question is worth
four or five or six it will just get one
okay so that's what you see that's how
it gets the rest of the marks are
assigned student working on that to show
you okay so let's have a go this is the
substitution may provide so you
differentiate okay now what you do at
this point there's a few different ways
to do it but I would probably write that
as given what I have here du equals one
on X DX because I can see one on X DX in
there so it's going to make a nice easy
substitutions okay
I've changed one of these parts of the
integral I've already got a substitution
for this because I defined it what's the
last piece that they need to account for
the substitution I'm gonna change the
limits right beginners error to change
everything else but forget to change the
limits so you drink somewhat the muscle
box like so this is the way it's often
set out in your known specimen solutions
for your original boundaries and then
the boundaries in your new domain we do
variable okay yep
all right so now what do I do I've done
all of my pre work now I can actually do
my substitution now here's a critical
point you want to look out for pay
careful attention to the working vet
your paper has put down you've really
got to do this in one hit I might do our
papers I believe in use now okay you
gotta be all X's and then all use have a
look and see if the person you're
marking has kind of done half and then
on the other half it's a big no-no what
you should have is this fully formed
let's see can you see it right so number
one I've changed the integrand number
two the variable of integration number
three the boundaries all of them in a
clean sweep okay can anyone tell me why
is it a bad idea to sort of do it in two
stages well three stages or any number
now probably the main thing the main
cause for concern is really the
boundaries okay because people will just
plain forgets to change the boundaries
but people get mixed up in here as well
okay so if you've got some exes and use
flying around that's really a bad thing
would it get to the HSC if the final
answer ended up being correct and
there's a good chance that it would okay
is it a good practice than what do you
sell fun probably not okay so then we go
on now I translated it all into use so
what is the primitive it should be minus
one all of you
you shouldn't it the powers minus two
you raise it to - one thing you divide
by that new power which gives you the
negative from one and I think that means
you'll get what happens if these units
over here has anyone put any units on
yeah yeah what what happens if this
unit's there that would be wrong because
it's an integral it doesn't have units
there's a lot to do with an area okay so
just watch off now maybe not to dog
locks but make a note a minute now just
a quick thought for you you have three
months of play with where we should put
well I would we already know if it's a
bull dancer one of the marks will go
here so then when you look at these
steps where would the other two marks
okay now people say substitution I'm
doing substitution in a lot of places
which place this is given I don't think
that's worth anything
how about here you think that's worth
the whole block the agency doesn't
recognize when the whole block okay I'll
tell you why it's because it's a very
very simple derivative like that it's
almost no work it's not really what's
being tested by this question okay where
are the marks there's one to get your
boundaries okay
the other mod is to do this whole piece
okay they don't let you say I'm going to
be here not a bit there then what I see
that you can do the whole lot okay so
one mark will be for translating the
boundaries what Mark is forgetting the
integrand and the variable of
integration of all my sitting together
and this is one reason why I said
someone to do it women understand okay
they got to hear and other stuff is
wrong that's not worth it